salut ceux qui me suivent sur les
réseaux sociaux savent que dimanche
dernier j'avais rendez vous avec le
patron je suis allé à londres 221b baker
street
sherlock holmes ouais mon gars et à la
place du générique je vous ai mis
quelques photos
tout ça m'a donné envie de vous raconter
une anecdote qui m'est arrivé durant le
séjour est peut-être que vous aurez une
réponse à ma portée à ça je arrivé à
londres en prenant le train à la gare de
saint-pancras et j'étais tellement
content durant le trajet que j'ai pas
réussi à me reposer du coup j'ai parlé
avec tout personnel de bord et le
contrôleur du train m'a raconté qu'un
jour il avait vécu avec son équipe une
synchronicité une synchronicité sa
hasard remarquable ils se sont aperçu
durant le trajet que trois des passagers
assis dans le train avait le même nom de
famille que le conducteur du train le
contrôleur et le serveur du wagon bar
comme si moi je prenais le train et que
le contrôleur s'appelait au lit car ça
s'appelle un homonyme donc sur les trois
passagers il y avait un homonyme du
conducteur à nos homonymes du serveur et
un homonyme du contrôleur je peux pas
vous donner les vrais noms de famille
mais disons que dans le désordre il
s'appelle winchester johnson et rampl ce
que j'ai pu savoir en discutant c'est
que le passager rampl habitent sur abbey
road
là où a été prise la fameuse photo des
beatles sur le passage piéton j'ai pu
savoir également que le serveur habite à
camden town dans les anecdotes j'ai
appris également que le passager qui
s'appelait johnson n'aimait pas l'avion
il en avait une phobie absolue ah oui il
faut savoir aussi que l'un des membres
du personnel donc le conducteur le
contrôleur ou le serveur winchester
gagne souvent quand ils jouent au
billard contre le contrôleur et je crois
pas vous avoir précisé que le passager
qui s'appelle comme le serveur habite à
notting hill et en parlant du serveur il
ya une autre anecdote c'est que le
serveur est inscrit à la même
bibliothèque de quartier que le passager
qui est pilote de ligne pour british
airlines et c'est vrai que dit comme ça
c'est un petit peu embrouillé ans parce
qu'avec toutes ces informations j'avais
du mal à savoir qui était qui et surtout
qui s'appelait comment et quand j'ai
demandé aux contrôleurs quel était le
nom de famille du conducteur du train il
m'a dit que j'avais assez d'informations
pour pouvoir le déduire alors je sais
plus si ça s'est vraiment passé ou si
j'ai tout inventé pour vous faire une
énigme aujourd'hui mais ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya une solution logique à
tout ça vous pouvez trouver le nom de
famille du conducteur de ce train et
c'est votre anime la solution je vais
vous la donner dans quelques secondes
dans la suite de cette vidéo donc ne
regardez pas tout de suite je suis sûr
que vous pouvez trouver et revenir voir
la solution ensuite pour voir si vous
aviez bon pour voir directement la fin
de la vidéo sans passer par la solution
je vous mets un lien dans la description
vous cliquez de suisse à vous emmène à
la suite et ça fait sauter la solution
d'ici là bonne recherche
alors prêts à entendre la solution le
conducteur du train s'appelle winchester
comme les frangins dans supernatural
chacun ses références on sait que le
passager qui s'appelle rand paul vi à
abbey road et que le serveur habite à
camden town
ça veut dire que le passager rampl n'est
pas le pilote d'avion puisque le pilote
d'avion habite dans le même quartier que
le serveur on le sait via leur
inscription commune à la bibliothèque de
leur quartier on sait aussi que ce n'est
pas le passager qui s'appelle johnson
qui est pilote d'avion puisque lui la
peur une phobie de l'avion
donc le pilote d'avion de la british
airlines est forcément winchester par
élimination et ça ça va nous servir
puisque on sait maintenant que le
passager winchester habite dans le même
quartier que le serveur on le sait
toujours grâce à la bibliothèque de
quartier ont déduit facilement que le
passager winchester habite à camden town
non c'est aussi que le passager rampl
habitat abbey road
ça veut dire encore une fois par
élimination que le passager johnson
habite à notting hill et comme il est
précisé que le passager qui porte le
même nom que le serveur habite à notting
hill
ça veut dire que le serveur a pendant
famille johnson mais souvenez-vous
winchester base souvent le contrôleur
lorsqu'ils jouent au billard ensemble
donc déjà le contrôleur ne peut pas être
une geste heures puisqu'il va pas se
battre lui-même c'est un des deux autres
et nous savons qu'ils servaient à cette
johnson donc le contrôleur est forcément
rampl
et de fait le conducteur du train
s'appelle bien winchester élémentaire
évidemment toute cette histoire était
inventée de toutes pièces pour vous
faire cette énigme aujourd'hui n'hésitez
pas à en parler dans les commentaires
mais je sais que certains vont dévoiler
la solution directement dans les
commentaires et ça c'est dommage par
contre je félicite déjà d' avance tous
ceux qui vont se retenir de mettre la
solution si vous aviez trouvé la bonne
réponse vous pouvez mettre un
commentaire et dans ce commentaire vous
mettez le hashtag élémentaire et moi je
serai que vous avez trouvé et les autres
aussi merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous aura
plu n'hésitez pas à faire tout ce que
vous voulez leaké abonnés etc
rendez vous demain à 17 heures ciao